but you are keeping busy building lego
sets which i'm used to because i have
children yeah but you were building lego
sets
how did that go i feel like there's i
don't know if if you were
oh boy it was amazing there she is um
i i don't know if you feel this way but
i feel like that was like covid season
one
like you know like where i like when i
say i i got some nods from the virtual
audience
like when i say like covet season one
and covet season two like we all sort of
know what that means yeah like and i
feel like that
legos were very coveted season one now i
don't know what to season to do
with depression yeah it was me just
staring at these legos like what do i do
with you
work through all your wine like that
yeah no i yeah i thought i would like i
was like oh i know what i'll do i'll
like take them apart
and give them to someone and now i'm
like right
i would have to just have so much red
bull in my system to want to take this
apart
bit by bit but if somebody's really ocd
and they want to take them off my hands
and like break them down
yeah and my kids are like are you done
mommy i love breaking them down because
we build them all and then i have like
individual
in our craft room they're all like color
coordinated like i'm
get out of here i find so much
satisfaction from organization oh i do
too
yeah oh yeah oh i love like i love like
pretty boxes
and i'm like very big like it i love it
i love a label maker
yeah thank you yeah thank you but thank
you
thank you thank you but um but i haven't
gotten all the way
you're at like a different level you're
at the open level of organization well
here's the thing i also have children
that legos are everywhere when you step
on them it really makes you so angry
inside that you just tell them they
should probably run
yeah um yeah away from yeah yeah why do
i exist why do you exist
like happening is making me question
everything
[Music]
you